We'll talk about skills today.
The current challenges about context.
And then lastly about the ecosystem
that's being built around skills lately,
especially with open cloud and
all of those stuff getting a lot of
attention in the industry.
So, let's get into it.
Every AI or agent tech app typically has
three layers. The one that user sees,
which is typically the UI, the user
interface.
The one that model sees, which is the
system prompt, as well as the tool
descriptions. And then the one that data
sees, which is the schema of data or the
input and output of the tool calls.
And these little bugs typically live on
these second and third one, which is
slightly hidden from the user.
And so, let's talk about these
problems.
The first one is that beautiful lie that
we've been told that the latest frontier
models have infinite context windows.
They typically promised that each one
has
1 million, 5 million, and even latest
models they promised us infinite context
window, which incorrectly shapes our
thinking perspectives about rag and MCP
in a sense.
Because if we consider that there's
infinite context window, we just think
that we can dump the whole list of
documents to the context
and expect it to magically work.
This applies to MCP as well. Let's say
we can write 100 tools and expect the
LLM to use or pick the right tool at the
right time. Which is typically not true.
Because in reality, the longer context
typically doesn't mean better
performance.
Because each time put more context into
LLM, that's one more place where the LLM
might be misled it or its context might
be poisoned.
In fact, there was a paper called
context rot,
and it proves that after
25% usage of the context window, so for
example, for 1 million token, if you
used 256K of it,
the performance starts to degrade.
So, I'm pretty sure it starts really
well as day in the life, but as time
goes and as the conversation grows,
let's say there is 100 prompt input and
output responses in your one shot, and
added 200 shots, and then each one of
them kind of calls MCPs or tools, each
time out of them in the middle fails,
and at the end of the day, the context
is almost eating itself in a sense that
the latest 100 model can perform
like a really poor model. I'm pretty
sure we'll have seen this, you are
absolutely right
from Cloud Code, even though
Phil's a sharing, then you're absolutely
right. At one point, makes you feel bad
that Cloud Code is making the same
mistake it made 5 minutes ago.
The second problem is mostly about
documentation websites.
This is an interesting statistics that
just from last year to this year, the
traffic to documentation websites
increased from 10% to 50% that's coming
from coding agents. The challenge here
is the fact that docs are written for
humans,
but models are expected in a different
format. Because docs typically require
some kind of intuition, asking for a
follow-up, or if you don't understand
it, well, you can just Google it quickly
and then find the answer for it. But
models typically doesn't have
those capabilities until you actually
build a context engine around it. I want
to add one more strategic point about
the future of enterprise AI and why we
think that skills might be a huge
contributor to where the enterprise
agents or enterprise AI is heading
towards.
Let's talk a little bit about modes
these days.
Now, if you want to understand modes
today or tomorrow, we can go back in
time at today's history of software to
see how has it been in the past.
Typically, the things that have been the
hardest to replicate have been the modes
for the software companies or even
hardware ones. So, for example, whoever
controls the hardware, the data, or
especially the integrations in the SaaS
era
would be the ones that would control the
market most of the time.
So, the real mode here would be friction
where you would make it genuinely hard
to you to leave to to make someone leave
your platform.
So, the core idea here is the switching
cost was too much that it it was just
hard to switch.
Now, these days we're hearing news where
Cloud Code would rewrite
100,000 or a million lines of code from
Python to Rust. So, basically, we're
getting really, really good at switching
codes and reducing it.
Now, we can have better tools, better
APIs, just better languages, and then
switching it in few days.
Now, skills are creating an entirely
different ecosystem where instead of
creating a friction mode, they're
actually creating fluency mode.
So, the core idea is switching the the
layer a little bit so that each time
your skill makes the experience better
for whoever is the one that that's using
your platform. And that fluency
compounds by experience.
The the real result that the users of
your platform is getting from here is
the experience.
If you would look at the definition of
experience, you can realize that it's
satisfaction or minimum amount of
friction between intent and outcome. So
basically, whatever the user is trying
to achieve through your platform,
achieving it in maybe minimum amount of
time or trying to optimize the whole
satisfaction layer or whole experience
layer of it.
If you look at the equation, you will
see that overall friction modes and
fluency modes are the opposite.
Friction modes are typically defensive.
So you're trying to make your experience
in a sense that someone wouldn't switch.
Now,
fluency modes are offensive in a sense
that you're making the whole experience
really nice in a sense that you're
making it genuinely hard for someone to
switch anyways because they like the
platform.
So we think that the feel of the thing
or the reliability of the outcome from
the start, which is your intent, to the
result is the whole experience layer.
And the skills are one of the best tools
that can actually, quote unquote,
commoditize that experience layer for
agents.
So,
the real mode in SaaS era might be the
core idea of skills, where you would
commoditize the feeling of your platform
or, in other words, how trustful or
reliable you are in terms of intent and
outcome equation.
When someone evaluates the platform,
they typically have a checklist of
things that they take a look, right?
They typically look at how secure your
platform is, are you compliant with all
sort of new standards that's that's
coming up every week.
How is my
data governance layer? Where is my data
stored? Are your SLA guarantees? Can I
see the logs of my agent? How about
tracing?
How is the integration layer? Are you
able to integrate to my auth layer
that's connected to my internal
on-premise systems? So now we think that
checklist really has a new item, a new
guy in the room, which is the
teachability.
Again, coming back to the experience
layer for agents, so here the core idea
is if someone is new or if my agent
harness is new to a platform, how easy
is it for that agent harness to pick up
that operational knowledge that you've
encoded a skill and apply directly and
then get into the result in less than
few seconds. So, the core idea of
teachability is to make that experience
easy as possible whenever someone wants
to use your platform for the first time
or for subsequent times.
So, if you wrap it up, we think that the
skills might play a huge role in the
enterprise AI or enterprise agent world
in a sense that it might define what the
mode is. If the mode these days is about
fluency, skills will help it in a sense
that the value that you are giving will
get compounded by each skill you add to
your platform.
Why think about standards? I feel like I
just need to skip this slide for this
audience.
Because standards are good, right? For
example, React came out
recently, but if you go back in time to
20 years ago, it almost feels like LLM
and agent ecosystem right now.
So, 20 years ago we didn't have React.
It introduces a philosophy on reactivity
and modularity to the to the way we
build apps.
And same for LLMs and agent ecosystem in
a sense that we don't yet have that
React moment. It's still up on here in
terms of how to systematically develop
really long-running agent systems.
And as I said, context engineering in a
sense is kind of a one attempt to to
solve that problem in an organized way.
So, if you would summarize what context
engineering is, it's almost an idea of
minimizing the amount of information
that flows to the LLM at the right time
so that we can filter so that we can
fill the context with the right
information at the right flow at the
right moment.
So, let's look at this example on the
right.
So, if you consider
a typical agent
whether it's cloud code or our own agent
that we built for a customer it
typically has system instructions
cloud that I need couple built-in tools
maybe also connection to MCP, right?
And on top of that
a user or a customer is kind of
prompting the LLM.
Typically this 40% is the smart zone
where the LLM can potentially perform
well.
But if you would you are getting past
this 40% context used
it typically goes into a
zone called dumb zone.
The core idea here is the fact that even
though you have 100% context available
for you, but as you go past 40% um then
you are actually getting really dumb
responses. So, the core idea here is is
to make sure that you're not passing 40%
even without starting to work with your
agent. So, imagine you have all sort of
the instructions, a lot of MCPs here,
and then you add one more block here for
another MCP, one more block here for
another MCP that's connected to
internet, one more for web search, and
things like that. And then
even you haven't ever chatted to your
agent yet
now you've filled your 40% context
window. And then when you just start to
chat for the first time, you start from
dumb zone from the first call.
So, typically creating a great context
has pieces to it.
Right? Let's cover each one of them
briefly. The first one is instructions
that kind of comes by default. You put
it to the system prompt. The second one
is external data. Maybe the user will
upload some PDFs or any kind of rag.
And execution history. Obviously, LLM
needs to have access to what happened on
that session. What's the past tool call
results and where are we in terms of
state?
And then latest agentic systems has
memory in a sense that they can remember
things across conversations.
And then the output schema, the the
correct way to output all of these stuff
to the user.
So, as you see, each one kind of adds
one more level of complexity to the
things that agent needs to handle.
And it almost creates an M times N
problem in a sense that one agent or one
LLM needs to be connected to all of
these stuff at once, at the same time,
at any time of the conversation.
Which is pretty hard task to do,
actually, if we would emphasize LLMs.
The core idea is instead of hardcoding
everything into either one of these
items, basically, and then loading it to
the LLM, we would progressively load
whenever those instructions is needed to
the LLM.
And then
LLM would have access to a piece of it
at runtime.
And then it can load it to its memory
whenever it's needed.
The problem that skills to be solved is
it enables a rich context access.
In a traditional context, everything
goes into
the context, which would lead to context
rot problem that we covered.
But with skills, those capabilities,
whether it's about web search or whether
it's about some capability that doesn't
exist in the main agent that lives
externally, and then LLM or agent can
have access to it.
So, if you would give an example and
compare it with MCP, typically, if an
agent is connected to an MCP server, it
even this number is really small for 15
MCP servers. If it's connected to 15 MCP
server, I'm pretty sure it's consuming
over 100,000 tokens per session just in
tool definitions itself.
Without starting the conversation yet.
But same operational headache becomes
really small, probably at least 10 times
smaller with skills.
Thanks to progressive disclosure.
So, this one is only exposed metadata of
skills to the agent or to the LLM at
runtime so that it can act like an index
in a database. Just like how indexes
work in a in a DB so that you can
quickly search for stuff. Same for the
metadata for skills. Even if skills
might have
thousands of tokens in it,
LLM has access to the metadata of it on
which most of the time leaves at the top
of the file,
which is being loaded to the to the
context on demand.
This creates mental model shift on
developers as well as the industry in a
sense.
Because the skills are are kind of
becoming almost like a framework across
platforms like cloud code, codex, and
then all of them supports this
perspective. Why, you would ask? Long
running agents, even coding agents are
acting like a general purpose agents,
right?
So, when a customer asks us to build a
supply chain agent or an agent that's in
a manufacturing space, we don't really
have to build a separate agent for that
specific use case. It's the fact that we
can still take the main general purpose
agent as the
as the engine and then put skills on top
of it.
But you see how skills creates a shift
in terms of perspective about how to
build solutions. In a sense that right
now you don't have to actually build the
agent itself, the engine itself, but
actually build skills for it.
And then that's way to switch agents
between industries, between different
domains.
All right, moving on to part two where
we'll cover briefly on skills versus
MCP. So, they kind of solve slightly
different problems in a sense. So, I
just want to clarify this. Both of them
are from Anthropic.
Both MCP and skills. So, they're not
competing for
a thing. So, in a sense that MCP kind of
definitions for what actions the agent
should take. In a sense that it doesn't
change the agent definition and then
what the agent is, what capabilities it
has.
And for skills, it's different in a
sense that it helps to think about
problem and then change you can
basically customize the way agent acts
through skills. How to think about this
problem. And then skills introduces you
a way to self-modify
in a sense that agent can modify or
update its own skills based on the
experience that it had with that skill.
On the other hand, for MCP, it's sort of
a server that sits in a separate
environment where the agent has access
to the use that tool, but it doesn't
have access to the code of that MCP tool
in a sense.
Anything to add here, Carson and others?
>> I I think this is a good opportunity to
answer to Jody's question. A thing a
skill can do is expose an MCP server. It
lets skills and agents say, "Here's your
MCP server."
It could also just actually you can dump
the tools that were in your MCP server
into your skill directly and the agent
can then execute them.
So, it can actually service and create
its own MCP server as part of a skill.
This is why we get so excited about the
robustness of skills versus MCP. It's
not just self-modification, which you
could replicate with MCP, right? MCP
with memory and caching and using
customization and using tool calls that
are actually agents themselves.
Those agents may even have their own
skills that you can specify as part of
the tool as load these skills and
execute this thing, right? Like there's
this kind of incestuous relationship
that still skills live on their own as a
distinct thing that can operate,
template-ize code, execute code, execute
MCP servers, build and create and run
and then therefore add to their root
context window new MCPs just all via the
skill. So, it's like an entire complete
package
of what an agent can become.
Essentially, Copilot could be a skill.
>> So, the core idea is use skills when the
hard blood hard part is just about
reasoning it or thinking in the right
ways.
But, MCP solves other problem for us in
terms of authentication, access, or the
horsepower if you want to actually
isolate the process for for some of the
execution that really requires a lot of
resources, then that's easy way to let
that have its own
>> server that can interoperate, right?
Skills run with your the agent's
machine.
So, there's a little bit of a
loop-de-doop, but they're still
sufficiently different that MCP, you
know, gets to live in its own world and
be a production piece of code and skills
get to be kind of viable. I think MCP is
intelligent adapts, which it is actively
working to adapt, right? It's the older
standard and the skills we didn't know
quite how powerful were we were until we
had 85,000 of them out there. You still
don't
want that hosting capability, right? I
don't have access to a GPU on my
computer that is sufficient in order to
do a significant operations or to do
semantic search across 400 terabytes of
documents.
In those cases, I still need a robust
hosted MCP server. The way I get my
agent to use that MCP server is you can
use skills to do progressive disclosure
for that MCP server that then has that
500 terabyte disk or that access to 75
GPUs or whatever it is that that tool
needs. So, they're still interconnected
in a way that they both have their uses
and are kind of inescapable. Use that
MCP server going to access data in a
restricted environment in your medical
records or or whatever that your
personal computer can't access. Does it
need resources that are unachievable on
the agent that you're executing on?
It's essentially a way to execute
remotely and and that still always has a
benefit.
>> And one last argument against MCP, which
might turn out to be interesting, is the
fact that it turns out that current
agents doesn't need a lot of tools. If
you go into the way Codex or cloud code
is developed, you will see that there's
only like a handful of tools that's
being run. It's not like there's
hundreds of tools that's being executed
in a in a separate MCP server, which
also proves the fact that a typical
skills folders or capabilities folders
with different options can replace MCP
as long as you have a good base
reasoning model.
All right. Skills has two different
readers. The first one is the front
matter, the top of the skill, which is
here. If you see an example of our one
of our skills,
you see that this is
almost part of that MD file, but this
acts like an index for that skill. So,
at run time, this is only thing that's
loaded to the agent's context, agent
system prompt.
But this one is loaded to the agent's
context, which is the body of it. So,
when I say there's two different
readers, the first reader is the agent's
runtime, which is the system prompt. So,
the reader for this one isn't the
context itself. It doesn't really burn a
lot of context because it's just a small
XML that has probably less than 100
tokens typically, which agent do have
access to prior to the execution.
And then second one is the markdown
body, which is read by LLM if activated.
If the LLM thinks that we need that
skill, then it will be loaded. So, this
is the first one, less than 100 tokens.
The second one, on activation, which is
typically less than 5K tokens. The level
three is what third one is, which is
scripts.
The scripts can be in two ways. For
cloud code, for example, they're
executable in a sense that their cloud
SDK or cloud code can actually execute
this get deployment features.py, and
then only put the output of that
execution back to the context. But a lot
of other examples, a lot of other
platforms supports this one, which is
also code, but not executable in a
sense. Just serves as a purpose of
example for the agent. So, three levels
of managing a simple skill. First one is
the front matter, second one is the
body, and third one is extra scripts or
context. Part four, talking a little bit
about the ecosystem and what's going on
around there. So, there is 26 plus
platforms that support this, right now.
Like cloud code, code X, code pilots,
Gemini CLI, and others. There is
probably at this point 100,000s of
skills out there, and then there is
marketplaces where people sell skills
for money. Devin Jensen talked about
Claude, Agent which is
registry for them.
That being said, we are also part of
ecosystem and we also published our open
source agent skills repository. This is
a really good demonstration of both the
power and the risks of agent skills.
Open Agent has become the repository
that has the most stars, beating Winix
and React.
And I feel like there is a lot of
marvelous ways they've done the context
engineering in a sense that works across
different apps and chat applications.
But I feel like probably a couple
details regarding their sub agents,
which kind of serves the purpose of
keeping the context clean, as well as
self-evolving skills, made it really
impressive for whoever looked at the
code.
The fact that it can kind of self-heal
based on the experience of it with
skills, as well as write its own skill
to extend its capabilities, in a sense,
scary, but what made a good impression,
the fact that this is just a coding
agent that has access to about 10 tools,
which can do anything for you, as long
as you have skills on top of it.
So, that kind of changes the way we
think about customers or enterprise
solutions in a sense that we just need
to develop one good agent, which is base
for everything, and then you can just
build skills on top, which solves your
domain-specific problems or whatever
your customers are asking for.
So, if Open Agent can write skills, then
let it write it, right? But this touches
the fact that typically, we need humans
to write skills. There's a lot of
research on this that's recently
published, but they published that
actually the LM generated skills hurts
the performance of LM in a sense that it
uses more tokens. It's it spends more
time to go and actually reason up about
the problem rather than helping it to be
faster or to use less context in a
sense.
>> [clears throat]
>> There's a lot of risks to consider here
if if the LLM is writing and executing
its own skills,
then
obviously there's ton of risks in terms
of prompt injection because everyone is
writing skills these days and then
publishing it out there. Pretty sure you
have seen on the news there's bad stuff
that that happened with open cloud.
And there is no isolation. One of the
advantages of MCP in the sense that the
isolate the process for your MCP and
your agent, but everything happens on
your laptop, on your agent, on your
environment.
And last one here is about the fact that
these marketplaces still lack the
verification control. Just like how NPM
was scary 10 years ago in a sense that
you would still check the number of
stars or who developed this before you
downloaded the package. Same for skills.
Closing thoughts. Context is a budget.
Context is almost like a limited
resource that we need to
carefully filter information. Definitely
the longer context doesn't mean better.
Every irrelevant file, every irrelevant
web search, or error message really
drags agent's attention and then you
lose a lot of reasoning power.
Skills are complementing MCPs at least
right now.
A skill is only as good as the human who
wrote it based on our experience.
And lastly, skills are software which
can take weeks to build so that we
should actually start versioning them,
evaluating and testing them, and
actually writing good skills. There's a
couple resources that we've used. Thank
you.